But how do you tell the difference between alkaline phosphatase going up due to bone metastasis
or from taking benvenazole or another drug? Is there anything to take to help the liver regardless
of cause? So yes, so remember a marker a blood marker is a sign that's a clue to something.
So if there was a drug that reduced alkaline phosphatase levels, would that be a good thing to take
if my alkaline phosphatase levels are going up? No, that wouldn't be good. I don't that's
what you're asking, but no, that would not be a good thing to take because we don't want to artificially
lower marker level that's telling us something. It's trying to tell us something. We don't want to put a
piece of tape over its mouth, but it's trying to tell us something. So how would you go through
a process of differential diagnosis with somebody who has metastasis to bone and is unfed metazole
and they have elevated alkaline phosphatase? Well a couple things. If my alkaline phosphatase is elevated
is my calcium also elevated, is my calcium moving in a direction of going up over time
along with my alkaline phosphatase? If the answer to that is yes, then it's more likely due to the
metastasis of bone because remember alkaline phosphatase will be elevated due to irritation in the
liver. That couldn't be from a drug, right? From fed metazole, one drug could be from chemo
therapy too, could be from other drugs, could be from Tylenol. So you could get an elevated alkaline
phosphatase with that. Many times with a drug, you'll also get an elevated AST and ALT, sometimes not,
but that would be another clue. But when you have metastasis to bone with bony destruction,
alkaline phosphatase is in bone two. So it will spill alkaline phosphatase. You'll get an elevated
alkaline phosphatase with bony destruction. But with bony destruction that elevated alkaline phosphatase
will more commonly be associated also with elevated calcium because you're going to get spillage
of calcium from the bone into the blood. So you're going to have with the differential diagnosis is
if I have elevated alkaline phosphatase and elevated calcium, it's more likely, nothing's going
to be perfect, but it's more likely due to bony destruction. If I have elevated alkaline phosphatase
and speared calcium, I mean my calcium is actually going down, but I also have elevated AST and
ALT that it's more likely due to irritation and liver from medication or whatever. It's like
could be for Mendezol. So that's partly how you would look at it, but you'd also look at
subjective things. Do I have more bone pain? Okay, that could be a sign that the elevated alkaline
phosphatase is coming from my bone. So there's other things that you look at too, but that's the key
component.